we're in an unmarked police car in
Croydon South London where there's a
stabbing a day and a ten percent rise in
knife crime already part of the officers
job is to disrupt the boroughs gangs the
only pal conditions where there are
gangs there are knives you've got money
now evasion have these two teenagers are
robbery suspects the stop and search
found no knives this time we've had
various stabbings all of these victims
are teenagers some still go to school a
lot of our normal robbery suspects are
12 13 years old and they're carrying
knives I've got no regard of what
they're doing and they have gotten over
got they have no respect and we we're
dealing with it either so don't care if
the police are gonna arrest him or chase
them London has just had its worst year
for almost a decade four fatal stabbings
there were 82 try to reverse the trend
there will be more stop and search a
controversial tactic which in the past
has alienated black communities who felt
they were unfairly targeted it is a fine
balance that has to be drawn stop and
search absolutely works as a policing
tactic : 10 Prime Minister it has no
effect on knife crime as a professional
police officer my position would be that
stop and search is an absolutely crucial
tactic in dealing particularly with
something like knife crime but have you
can wear partitions that it's the right
thing to well I think we convince
politicians by effectively using stop
and search and getting the results that
we need from stop and search and
managing some of those community
tensions that you described
an increase in stop and search has
forced some knife users to hide their
weapons somewhere they can retrieve them
in a hurry the police make regular
weapon sweeps in Peckham another part of
South London on a troubled estate
officers found two knives within half an
hour they're just left around in these
areas to be used as weapons and picked
up by gangs and and other violent
individuals so when we stop and search
them on the streets they won't have them
on them they'll be ready to hand if they
come into conflict in this area they'll
be able to pick them up easily and use
them police realize long ago that
enforcement alone would not solve knife
crime really where we need to get to I
think both police and everybody
collectively is reducing the number of
young people that think it is either
desirable or acceptable to carry a knife
because of all the consequences and as
you say we have schools officers who are
in pretty much every school in London
and giving talks to the children at all
levels through the school in terms of
making responsible decisions about a
whole range of things but particularly
around nice while London struggles
against rising knife crime in Glasgow
it's a different story twelve years ago
a United Nations report branded Glasgow
the most violent city in the developed
world we had a homicide rate involving
nights that was three and a half times
higher than anywhere else in Europe
anywhere else three and a half times the
number and a sort of homicide anywhere
else in Europe we didn't know why and
and I still don't know why but we just
we knew enough to say look let's take an
a so at us and we did have stop search
because stop search is important but
it's only important in the context of a
whole range of other things to stem the
wave of Glasgow knife attacks John
Connor can set up the violence reduction
unit his groundbreaking approach was to
bring in other agencies the scheme was
later rolled out across Scotland we got
all the guys for putting gangs we
brought them together about 80 or 90
attain and we said we've had enough at
us the communities had enough of us
you've had enough of us it needs to stop
and when you stop will help you do other
stuff and the gang stuff was a huge
success huge success because we had
social work involved we had education
weird health we had the courts where
communities we had youth groups but this
Glasgow workshop prison leavers are
taught new skills they're paid and given
help to find jobs it's just part of the
multi-agency initiative this has proved
so successful twelve years on the model
is now funded by the Scottish Government
and it's still working
the annual murder rate in Scotland has
more than halved from 137 to 61 I think
we're seeing a better understanding of
the the background of violent crime we
know that at its heart violence comes
from an equality it comes from
deprivation it comes from pure housing
and education it comes from adverse
childhood experiences it comes from a
young man who've suffered often physical
emotional sexual or violent abuse of
some sort in their in their younger
years and it comes from a whole host of
different causes and we know that the
police alone cannot solve that issue it
has to be solved by society as a whole
by politicians by local authorities by
the community themselves scintilla
joined us husbands
on the internet there are many vivid
reminders to police in London of the
challenge they face the crews of the
Croydon robbery cars have experienced
similar extreme violence drug deal gone
wrong and someone's brought a knife to
the deal and they've ended up being
stabbed with it
after stabbing someone has a massive
fight and it was all quite very nasty in
there cold blood in East London I was
taken to meet a gang member who went to
prison for stabbing someone he said his
name was Dylan and he wore an animal
mask to hide his face other said you had
to do what I did I said that I need the
money in their town
and I said this guy walked past me in a
mess Rolex so had to stab him to get
that eat enough up so I had to 776 times
that sounds like you nearly killed him
Dylan said he knew where to get a knife
if he needed one but he was trying to
turn his life around
will you ever leave use a knife again in
my life what did they help me I met a
nice girlfriend now some just found the
team I left
yeah but lots of other people are still
using knives what would you say to them
and then putting on a knife stay in
school stay in college and get off this
road left that's what I would say yeah
I've been there done that
it's not good Dylan is being guided
towards a new life by gangs line a small
group of ex gang members who advise
police and local authorities on
understanding the culture they're
dealing with I trained them on
understanding the lifestyle
understanding what again
remember things like so before you go
and arrest somebody or before you look
at somebody in a certain way you need to
understand where he came from and what
was the root causes to some of the
issues that he was faced with and when
you understand a gang member you have
communication when you have
communication you can now actually speak
with that person say hey well I know I
can do this to actually help you
everyone we met had a view on what could
help to bring down knife crime in London
London's police have studied what their
colleagues have done in Glasgow and are
adopting much of it will that work if
you look at the the model that they've
adopted in in Glasgow in Scotland that
essentially is really our because I
don't think in there there is any
particular one aspect that you could
pull out and think if we do this it'll
all be it will all change what there is
is a very coordinated effort to bring
everyone's ability to bear on a problem
that was a very serious problem the
police clearly have a very big role
not easy to compare London and Glasgow
the two cities are very different in
size ethnic mix
cup but they faced the same high levels
of knife crime and perhaps one can learn
from the other Martin brunt Sky News